so um let me just sort of tell me or
introduce myself so I'm a computer
scientist with background in machine
learning one of the people who here in
London organizes the London machine
learning meetup some very very
passionate about machine learning um in
a previous life I was a I was doing most
of my development on the sort of the
Microsoft stack and I was one of the
founders of the math net numerical
library which is kind of like the numpy
in the.net world but as I moved jobs and
joined the data science team at range
ban which is the startup that I work for
today and I sort of made my way into the
Python world and have enjoyed it very
very much and so what I want to talk
about today is the first project that I
did when I joined this startup range
band so very very quickly water what our
company does or startup does is we're an
e-commerce company we have a catalogue
of products and we have an order
processing system and we try to help big
retailers like Tesco and as then Argos
here in the UK that sort of scaled their
range so what that means is Tesco would
come to us and say look range band we'd
like to sell 500,000 books that we don't
have in our catalogue can you help us
and then we say yes we give them the
product data they send us orders and you
know from people and we ship it to those
people we deal with the returns etc so
you know in this kind of e-commerce
world there's a lot of you know
interesting machine learning problems to
tackle so one of the things that we have
is a sort of a search engine that we
give to the retailers where they can
make their selection and say look you
know I want to you know have a bunch of
you know electronics audio audio
components that I want to sell and well
range band has 75,000 of those and so
the retailer goes to that and they say
they select those they say they create
the short list and they lounge them now
sort of the key bit about this is that
the lot of the navigation that people
use on this search engine and the way
kind of retailers think and organize
their their teams is according to
product categories and so one of the
really important things that we need to
do is across the you know one
of millions of products that we have or
that we know about we need to categorize
them and so when I joined range ban we
had you know there was a I was one of
the very early technical people and so
the the people that were already there
the way they went about categorization
is you know they just contracted it out
to em you know Mechanical Turk or to
sort of companies in in countries you
know with lower wages and just had
people manually label label products so
you know they'd see an iPad and they'd
say oh and iPad is electronics computer
equipment tablets you know etc and it
seemed like this was a very good
opportunity as kind of like a first
project to tackle and automate this and
so essentially what the problem was that
I was going to solve a few years ago was
we have a product catalog it's
structured as a tree it has about 4,000
nodes in it about 2,800 of those are
leaf nodes there's about 21 top-level
categories like electronics clothings
toys etc and every product that you can
think of needs a category in this
hierarchical structure the good thing
was that because you know I joined a few
men few months after the company was
founded that you know there had been
humans labeling products you know for a
while before I joined so there was a
great data set for me to start with
however there were also hundreds of
millions of products that hadn't been
classified so there was still a you know
a big challenge so I'll walk you through
the sort of pipeline that I've built for
this I mean this is sort of work from
three years ago so there's things that I
might do differently but you know and
I'll touch on on that but so the the
first bit and I'm not going to spend too
much time on this is the kind of what I
did for the feature extraction stage so
you know at the top we have products and
our products are sort of you know the
way we get them by crawling the web or
from our suppliers or you know there's
sort of semi structured text so you
we have sort of a key like the name of a
product manufacturer description which
might be no and we might have a label
you know humans might have actually said
to us already what this product which
category this is and you know we do we
did standard things like you know we did
text cleaning we did we built our actual
feature features that we use our uni
grams and bigram features on the on the
text and then the one interesting thing
that we actually build sort of a little
bit later on but which which
dramatically improved performance was we
sort of added LD a topic feature so on
every product we looked at the item name
in the description we ran a top topic
model over the hundreds of millions of
products that we have that topic mod is
completely unsupervised so we can do
that for the labeled and unlabeled data
we train a topic model that had I think
the one in production has 50 topics and
we choose all the topics that have sort
of have a probability higher than I
don't know a point one or something and
we add those kind of IDs of those topics
as extra features and one of the things
that has helped us quite a bit with this
is this this Python Jenson library which
you know is a great library for doing
topic models it does it has
implementations of sort of stochastic
variational inference so it's very very
fast now like I said I didn't want to
spend or I don't want to spend too much
time on the feature extraction but I
kind of really want to talk to you about
you know how we set up this kind of
hierarchical classification task so I'm
going to talk to you now about you know
how we train this model how we you know
test it and how we do the labeling now
hierarchical classification is is kind
of an interesting or you know it's an
interesting problem and one that I
hadn't sort of touched on before I
tackle this project there's really two
ways you can go about about hierarchical
classification sort of the simplest way
you could go about it is by taking your
hierarchy so in this case there's sort
of a root node there's two top
categories a B and C a and C are
actually leaf nodes in this case and D
and E are you know child categories of
the of the beat category and so one
thing you could do is say you know look
I'm just going to forget about the fact
that I have a hierarchy and I'm just
going to flatten this this hierarchy and
I'm going to create a five-way or well a
four-way classifier that just you know
I'm going to train it and the my
supervisor or my label data that goes in
you know it just the training point with
label a CD or E and you know you could
be you could put up for debate if you
want products to be to allow to be able
to sit in an internal node of the tree
then you know you could add B as well I
mean some article classification tasks
you know require you to label straight
down into the leaves so that's one way
to solve hierarchical classification and
it's it's very easy because now you can
take your favorite multi class you know
classify or you know throw your data at
it and your problem-solve now for you
know a small hierarchy like this it
probably would be a wise thing to do
because it just simplifies things quite
a bit now if you have kind of a large
hierarchy and sort of ours with you know
four thousand nodes is I guess it's it's
somewhere in the middle you know there's
even you know just much much bigger
hierarchies then you know having a
classifier that hat you know it needs to
classify among four thousand or
discriminate among four thousand classes
or you know even more you know that
that's not a great idea and I'll touch
on this this problem in a bit so you
know the alternative is okay well for
every internal node of the tree I'm just
going to create a classifier that says
you know look if I know well at the
start you're at the root node if the
first decision I need to make is you
know am I in in in subtree a subtree B
or subtree see if you're an A or C while
you're done if you're in subtree B well
then you train just you train another
classifier and in that classifier is you
know binary classifier and just decides
whether you're in subtree D or E or in
leaf node D or e so now you train two
classifiers and and you know you kind of
use the structure of the problem a
little bit more so why is this so these
are the two choices that you can make
and I'll touch on on that a little bit
towards the end because it's an
important decision you need to make we
and sort of in the rest of the talk we
sort of we went for this particular
solution just because you know I you
know we had a tree with four thousand
nodes we allow products to end up in all
the nodes except for the top-level
category node so you know four thousand
minus twenty one node so you know we
thought that you know using this
structure would have been
would have been would be the right
approach so this is what we're going
with further for the rest of the talk so
then the next problem is okay well you
know which classifier am I going to use
and to be perfectly honest I personally
or the main motivation for making this
choice is you know finding a classifier
where you know all the work we put into
feature engineering could you know could
really benefit from so a classifier
where you know we sew the classifier
that we end up and a classifier that
supports multi class because you know
our tree is not a binary tree so we need
to be able to support multi-class
classification and and you know so we
ended up choosing logistic regression
but to be perfectly honest you know I
didn't try very many other ones with
discretion it's just a very very easy
one on that sports multi class and you
could just throw any features at it and
it's it's fairly good at figuring out
which features are important so we went
with logistic regression and just kind
of as a as a as a you know for those of
you who aren't familiar with logistic
regression it's it's the simplest model
ever so imagine you have a particular
word a particular document and the words
in that document are cartridge Samsung
black and ink that sounds like it might
be printer ink product so now you you
already know that it's somewhere in the
printer sort of leaf and there's sort of
two options it could be printer ink or
printer hardware
now there's two classified
or the classifier in this printer node
has parameters for you know the printer
ink label and parameters for the printer
hardware label and these are the values
and the way the the classifier works is
very very simple
you just look at all the features that
are you know available in your document
so cartridge Samsung black and inks of
the printer they're not in our document
so we ignore those you literally just
sum up all those values so you know for
printer ink you say 4.0 0.5 0.5 a 5.0 so
you get a value of 10 for printer
hardware you get a value of minus 0.6
and then you simply you know
exponentiate those numbers so you
definitely get two positive numbers you
normalize them to 1 and you get
probabilities out so then that's kind of
crucial is first you know what's going
to come later is we wanted to get
probabilities out of every every sort of
local classification for every subtree
we want to get a probability out so in
this case you know not surprisingly you
know if you have the cartridge samsung
black ink cartridge let's say that was
the document it's quite likely as
printer ink and this particular
classifier which i you know made up says
you know with ninety nine nine percent
probability if this is printer ink so
that's what that's what the logistic you
know regression does in equations this
is what it does so it literally you just
sum up all the features that you find in
your in your documents you exponentiate
them normalize them into one and those
are your probabilities so okay so we
take that we take this logistic
regression classifier so this is the
model this is how if you knew the
parameters of the classifier this is how
you you know get your probabilities out
and so now you have to actually figure
out the these parameters these you know
these beta parameters in this equation
so you need to figure out the the
parameters for your logistic regression
classifier and there's a wealth of tools
out there that can help you with this so
what these tools generally do is they
look at the
they kind of optimize a particular
objective function and the objective
function for logistic regression what it
consists of sort of two components so
the first component is you look at all
your dock you are you label documents
you take a particular set of parameters
beta and you look at the probability
that these parameters beta give to the
labels of your documents and you know
for some reason you know you take the
logarithm of those of those
probabilities and you sum them up over
all your documents so that first bit
essentially says you know given this
parameters beta how good are they in
classifying your labeled documents so
that's sort of your error you want to
minimize that error now the sort of bit
that comes that comes or that generally
people add to it is you know you want to
make sure that you don't over fit your
classifier so you want to make sure that
the parameters that you choose are not
too finely tuned to the data you're
given and generally the way people do
that is by making sure that those
parameter are as close to zero as
possible so you know by default you sort
of assume that a word doesn't matter to
particular classification tasks and you
really have to have strong evidence from
your data to make sure that parameter
goes away from that so there's sort of
two what people generally call
regularization terms that you add to
this optimization problem and so these
these you know this software tries to
solve this mathematical problem and
they'll give you these parameters which
then you know you can plug in and you
can start classified documents so the
there's sort of three things uh that's
sort of interesting to know about doing
this first of all you know there's some
sort of hyper parameters there's some
this sort of lambda1 and lambda2 which
essentially mean you know how strongly
do you want to constrain and regularize
these parameters how strongly do you
believe that they're all zero how strong
how much data do you need to see before
you're convinced that you know the word
cartridge you know probably means that
you're talking about an ink cartridge
you're not in card wear so you have
these you've sort of introduced in this
mathematical problem you've introduced
these extra parameters that you
you know somewhat need to choose and you
know you could you could ask yourself
well is there another mathematical
problem I can solve to you know to
choose the best ones but the generally
what people do is just literally you
know you just try a whole bunch of these
parameters and we call them hyper
parameters you just try a whole bunch of
those you check on a certain test set
you know how well each of them do and
then you go with the best ones so so so
what that's essentially what we do so we
just try you know I think in in our
production system we tried 20 of these
values and we sort of adjust them over
time but we tried 20 of these hyper
parameter values and trainer models with
these 20 numbers and just look at which
one does the best the other thing or so
the one thing that I kind of want to
point people to is well again I have to
say this is this is from a few years ago
and the software that we used I think is
is poorly known in the community so
there's this piece of software called
Wapiti which is written by a I think a
PhD student in Paris which is you know
it's it's exceptionally good software
for two things well one sort of its main
purpose is for sequence labeling so
labeling you know sentences or you know
sequences of data which is not what we
do but if you just forget about the
sequence you can actually just use it as
logistic regression and it's extremely
well written it's vector ah you know
it's C vectorized C code extremely fast
it's you know we've sort of found a few
bugs but you know they've kind of you
know they've been they're extreme or the
guys extremely quick with our aim them
out and so you know I can highly
recommend having a look at this piece
software if you need to do sequence
labeling or logistic regression think
right now um there's a lot of other
options available you know like this I
could learn took it has you know great
support for that you know at back then
this is kind of what I what I found and
what I which I trusted quite a bit so we
use Wapiti to solve this mathematical
problem Wapiti gives this models back
and a model is essentially just sort of
a choice of the
of the numbers that I sort of showed
here a model is literally just for every
word and every possible label kind of a
number and Wapiti gives us these back
and you know that's that's that's what
training consists of so how do we go
about this kind of in practice well okay
so this is this is the ID now so we need
to train one classifier for every
internal node in the tree so the way we
do that is sort of logically is we take
our tree and I've sort of simplified it
dramatically so imagine there's just the
root node and there's two internal nodes
the electronics node than the clothing
node and we've got our data set sitting
on top and so the first thing is we take
sort of every data point and we sort of
drop it down the tree and let's say this
is this is a data point that is let's
say an audio cable so it sits in the US
it's somewhere in the electronics
subtree so we spread it around the tree
and that data point that document is
going to give us one label labeled
training point for the root classifier
so it's going to we're going to use it
to train the root classifier - you know
distinguish between electronics and
clothing so you know we create now we
create two data sets one for the route
classifier and one for the electronics
classifier we're going to take that data
point and sort of copy it in those two
data sets similarly we take a next data
point you know again it's an electronics
data point so we you know spread it
around all the classifiers that we need
to train we take a third data point this
is a clothing one again we spread it
around it provides a training example
for the route classifier as well as a
training example for the clothing
classifier and we do that with oops we
do that with our whole data set so what
we've essentially done is for a for
every training point that let's sit
let's that sits let's say five levels
deep in the tree we've sort of copied it
five times it provides a training point
for the route classifier for the first
layer sort of top level classifier
second layer third layer fourth layer
that's it so we go and sort of copy our
data points and sort of spread them
spread them around every internal node
of the tree and then we're going to
train a classifier for
every internal node of the tree it'll
come to how we do that in a second so
that's kind of the main mechanism
logically and I'll again come back in a
little bit how we do that physically in
encode okay so we have made a choice of
our class for our classifier logistic
regression we're going to have one for
every node in the internal node in the
tree we have kind of a logical scheme
and algorithm if you want for spreading
our data set or deciding which training
point is going to go into which
classifier as you know for training so
now we need to go and train these train
these classifiers and there's sort of
two numbers that we then go and look at
at a first sort of at a first stage so
we train every classifier and we do two
things to sort of just two numbers that
we look at to see how well they how well
the classifiers work so the first thing
which is I mean both are very very
standard but just to recap first we do
cross-validation so you know let's say
the root classifier and we have you know
I think we'd probably have about a
million data points training data points
in our root classifier and we split
those million data points up in chunks
of two hundred thousand two hundred
thousand two hundred thousand two
hundred thousands and so we split them
up in five chunks we train on four
chunks and test on the fifth we train on
chunk one two three and five and ten
test on the four chunk we train on one
and two four and five we test on the
third chunk we do that for every chunk
so every chunk is in the training sort
of set four times and in the tests at
one time and every time you know we can
be on that sort of little local test set
we compute an error so we get sort of
five errors and we average those and you
know that gives us a kind of an estimate
an estimate of our of our of our total
error we so that gives us an estimate
for every local classifier of the error
and then you know there's another number
that we look at which is you know if we
what we want so the
cursey is one thing that you might be
interested in another thing you might be
interested in is well if you if the claw
is that the probabilities that your
classifier comes up with they're
actually correct so if you know you take
all the data points for which your
classifier says with 0.9 probability I
think this is in category 1 well then if
you look at all the tree all the points
that you know it assigned to point 9
probability you want about 90% of those
to be correct so that's what it's called
calibration that's another number that
you can compute for every classifier and
so we look at those numbers and get a
sense of how well our classifier is
doing and particularly we look at the
cross-validation error to decide which
say across different hyper parameters
which classifier that we want to go with
in the future so ok so now we have all
these local classifiers and now the
question is well how do we actually
label an actual product so now we take
any product that we had don't have a
label for we send it to the root
classifier and the root classifier says
you know what I think it's 90%
electronics 10% that it's a clothing
product all right so we do brute force
we go down to the electronics classifier
now we ask you know we already know what
we assume that your electronics what
probability are you audio/video
computers tablets accessories whatever
that classifier says I think 90% audio
10% video and 0% you know and everybody
else instead of we let these sort of
data points go down to tree like that so
that's essentially using Bayes rule sort
of every classifier gives us sort of one
chunk of the probability and we do the
greedy thing so we go down one path of
the tree to to to label these products
now why is it so crucial that we sort of
get these probabilities get these
probabilities out like I said now we
have a lot of people labeling things and
one of the things that I want to do is
you know I want to I wanted to keep
growing this data set so our classifiers
get better but I wanted to use kind of
you know our automation this machine
learning technology to also help them
the human sort of label of things that
you know are most important
the things you know which would make the
most impact to improving the classifier
so one of the things that we did was
with its some active learning so kind of
the picture that I like to paint is
let's say you have a classifier and the
root classifier needs to decide between
electronics and clothing or between
pluses and minus so in the top left
corner you know this is a this is a a
great case so you have a bunch of
unlabeled data points the black dots
we've got two red dots a blue cross if
you need to train a classifier it's
pretty pretty easy for the classifier to
figure out we know where does the line
is that divides up to two classes so
that's sort of the nice case
unfortunately you're you know the
world's not always that nice you might
be in that case so you have a classifier
but now you have these two green dots
which are very very close to the to the
classification boundary you know it
might be that you know the the dot on
the left is actually a red one and the
dot and the dot on the on the right is a
blue is really of the blue class and so
you know if things are close to the
decision boundary well that probably
means it's a good one I mean you really
don't know what's going on so it's
probably a good one to ask a human about
and similarly you might have sort of a
decision boundary sort of the flat line
and you have sort of a data point way
out which would correspond to say it's
described by words that your classifiers
have never seen in that case you know
it's again it's probably a good data
point to ask about you know if the first
time you know a vuvuzela was put on the
market
you know our classifiers didn't know
what vuvuzelas were that we'd never sold
any you know because we'd never seen
hoover Zillah in the description so you
know labeling that once and saying that
vuvuzela is I don't know what you want
to call it a toy that you know that
helps the classifier a lot because you
do that once maybe twice and you know
for the future your classifiers know
that boo boo sellers are toys so you
know by looking at you know how close or
how sort of not knowledgeable the
classifier is you can make a very good
decision about which which data points
you should send to humans for further
labeling and improving your classifiers
and which data points you know you
probably shouldn't shouldn't be bothered
with so what we do is we essentially do
our labeling and then
all these products that are close to
decision boundary which you know has a
switch can be translated into the
probabilities that you end up getting
and generally probabilities being low
and low you know what there's some math
behind what really what low is you you
sort of identified those and then we
send them to Mechanical Turk for further
labeling and put them back into our
training set so okay so that's
essentially sort of the logical bit of
our whole set up so very brief you know
how do we physically implement this so
the feature extraction I mean you know
we have hundreds of millions of products
it's sin it's like simply map operation
like for every training point you need
to do a bit of cleaning at the LDA
feature so you know there is a simple
MapReduce task the training is one that
I'll come to next which is slightly more
interesting so for the training phase
you know let's think of how many
classifiers we really need to train so
let's say we have about two thousand
internal nodes or two thousand
classifiers that we we want to get at
the end
now for every classifier said we're
doing five fold cross validation so we
need to actually train this classifier
five times you know with five different
sort of configurations of training and
test data okay so that's five times two
thousand plus you know we choose to use
or to search over about 20 sets of hyper
parameters so that means there's about
200 thousand classifiers that we need to
run and say the route one you know uses
the whole data set so it's quite an
expensive calculation to do you know the
one that says gaming consoles well
there's really only like you know half a
dozen gaming consoles in the world so
there's only you know five or six
training points and five or six
unlabeled points and so you know that
that's very easy but generally there's a
lot of work that needs to be done so
kind of in pseudocode the way we've kind
of approached it is kind of the or the
extreme way we've initially approached
it is okay so you you run a map job over
your whole data set and you look at a
labeled data point and you look at its
lineage and for every subcategory in its
lineage you want to send that data point
to the the internal node for
classification so that's what the first
for loop does
then for every hyper parameter you also
want to do you also want to send that
data point to that sort of classifier so
you know that's kind of another for loop
and then for every fold that you're
going to do in our case five fold cross
validation you also want to send that
data point to that particular fold so
what we end up with this is kind of like
in your mapper you know you take a data
point and you send it to everybody who's
going to you know train on that data
point which is you know a lot and then
in your reduce phase we then generally
just take our rapid decode you know put
all the data into it you know we get the
stats back out and now we've trained all
our models so you know it's very easy
you know and MapReduce might be a bit of
overkill here but it's very easy to use
kind of this MapReduce logic to just
organize the way you're doing your
computation so we do this using a Python
tool called dumbo which is a very good
tool for that we get all our models out
and then when we actually you know this
side okay these in these in these in
these models are sort of the best models
that we can we can do then we need to go
back and label the rest of our you know
100 million data set any way we do that
is we just take our data set hundreds of
hundreds of millions of products we
chunk it up you know in our case we do
128 chunks I mean and we just take one
simple machine that goes through every
chunk and then you know follows down you
know goes down the tree and you know
labels all the data points and puts does
the brute force sort of going down to
tree and labeling every data point so so
that's about it there's a few extra
things that we do but I thought there's
sort of a few things that I kind of
wanted to highlight of you know what we
did so I have to say you know this I've
talked a lot about the training and the
labeling all that because that's kind of
the interesting bit from from an
algorithmic or machine learning point of
view to be perfectly honest most of the
time spent in developing this we've
spent in the feature engineering is like
okay let's take the deep I to the
products name in the description how are
we going to clean it or shall we add LD
a feature like those kind of decisions
really make you know particularly with
in combination with the logistic
regression classifier which can you know
easily handle lots of features made the
biggest sort of impact in improving the
performance of our system
so most of our time is spent in the
feature engineering the another thing
that I have wanted to do for the last
you know two and a half years since this
thing has been in production is and this
is question of you know if you know that
if you know the the classifier that
classifies things the route classifier
so you have a good route classifier so
you know what's electronics clothing you
know luggage etc etc then there's a
question of knife you're going to train
the electronics classifier well do you
want to train from scratch like are you
going to just assume that you know
nothing about the parameters perhaps you
know no there might be some relation
between the parameters of the route
classifier and the electronics
classifier for example the words that
were very indicative of you know
distinguishing between clothing and
electronics might not be indicative at
all you know for distinguishing between
video and audio within the electronics
classifier and so being able to tie
these parameters across the classifiers
in the tree you know might allow you to
sort of really use some statistical
power and get better results so that's a
question that I haven't tackled yet and
there's sort of there's some really cool
work that people have done like held
amazed and some work around
frustratingly easy domain adaptation you
could imagine sort of every one of the
classifier being sort of a separate
domain that you want to solve there's a
lot of work that can't that you know can
be done there I haven't tackled it but
it'd be an interesting question and then
coming back to this idea between
flattening and and keeping your
hierarchy so this is really an
interesting problem there's again some
results from learning theory that where
people have looked at this where you
know what do you want to do you know if
you have a one classifier with you know
lots of classes that could potentially
be better than multiple classifiers
because the multiple classifiers if you
say need to using Bayes rule chain you
know the results of five classifiers
together so you're making five
classification tasks there's also five
times the probability of making an error
and so if you have you know really good
classifiers you know they're they're you
know 0.95% accurate you know that the
chance if you
than five times in a row the chance the
total accuracy is not not going to be
even close to 0.95 you know it's going
to be 0.9 5 to the power 5 which is
going to you know it's deteriorating
very quickly you know as the tree
becomes deeper so there's kind of an
interesting balance that you can strike
between you know should I flatten or
keep the hierarchy and I think there's
some some there's something to be gained
by you know at the high up the tree to
use the hierarchy so you know the root
you definitely want to first split
electronics away from clothing away from
you know luggage etc but then as you go
down the tree once you're in a very
niche category you know you might still
have a subtree with say 16 leaves but it
might be better to then just use a
multi-class classifier to reduce your
error rate and there's some learning
theory work around you know how to
strike that balance but you know we
haven't implemented just because it's
it's a lot more complex so that's about
it I'll take any questions on on this
this particular work so thank you okay
so so the first question was why we use
logistic regression versus sort of an
SVM or knife base or something
and again I it might be better to use
something else we just wanted something
where we could easily try to add new
features and you know play with the
features and do feature engineering I
mean in my experience that's been you
know where you can really gain a lot in
performance by you know doing more
feature engineering rather than focusing
on the particular algorithm which is why
we went for logistic regression and
there were good tools available I mean
your second question was that there's an
alternative software yeah I'm you know
there's lots of you know I think
different software around and you know I
think right now think Wapiti definitely
has a special place in my heart so I
could learn has another special place in
my heart
you know I there's a lot of things that
I would consider using it's really it's
just a matter of what you know I'm used
to that yes so that's good so the
question is whether we benchmark this
against the full flat full flattening of
the hierarchy yes we did that and the
full flattening of the heart
well that's very easy to do and you know
we did that at first on kind of our
initial training set and we got better
results with you know doing kind of an
initial version of the hierarchy which
is why we decided to spend the effort in
doing the hierarchal thing and to be
perfectly honest I'm not 100% sure we're
you know I'm sure it's problem dependent
as well but where the balance is between
when do you flatten when do you go for
the you know hierarchy but no obviously
comparing this to completely flattening
is very easy to do so so the metric we
used for that yeah and that's a very
good question and I sort of skipped over
that is all the cross validation that we
show is local you know that's just about
choosing which local classifier and so
one of the things that we do is you know
we do to start out with taking a whole
bunch of label data completely out of
the system and then look at the
performance of the you know the actual
performance of labeling you know
complete you know the complete labeling
now it's very hard to do because these
these the you don't get very good
accuracy because for example if you
label an iPad case you know iPad cases
end up in electronics accessories as
well as luggage and phone accessories so
they're actually two there's two or
three nodes that are actually reasonable
and if your classifier does a good job
by you know dropping in one of them but
your labels the other one they you know
you make a mistake and that's very
costly so you know and we haven't spent
a lot of time in figuring out you know a
different cost function for that but you
know we do look at that as a metric but
it's not the most important one because
we don't think it's a very good one yes
is a very good question where does the
tree come from is very simple answer we
use the tree from google shopping
because it's you know it's widely used
so it's a fork or not even a fork a copy
of the Google Shopping hierarchy because
it's it's a common one and we just you
know one yeah so we don't explore that
ourselves that is a good question ah we
didn't do that no we we literally just
run
Lda / or whole product catalog and the
reason we start we thought it might be a
good idea is that you know it helps with
things like you know you know senate
word synonyms like fit you know rather
than having two separate words you know
i'll pick up their sort of synonym like
and then you know there's a feature for
that but I think now be really
interesting things to do hierarchal Lda
over the tree yeah I think that would be
a cool idea yeah